der kampf um die beste sonnenliege auf
teneriffa geht weiter und diese
touristen heben ihn auf ein ganz neues
level denn hier werden die kinder ins
rennen geschickt und paradise park hotel
öffnet der pool jeden tag pünktlich um 9
uhr für frühaufsteher grund genug sich
schon mal in startposition zu bringen um
die beste liege zu ergattern und diese
bilder aus dem juli zeigen
peinlicher geht's nicht möchte man
denken aber wozu hat man kinder und muss
sich ja nicht selbst blamieren die
kleinen pfützen los um ihre handtücher
auf den sonnenliegen zu platzieren oder
gehört das etwa zum täglichen kinder
animationsprogramm den kleinen scheint
das wettrennen jedenfalls spaß zu machen
sie machen sogar fast einen sport daraus
ring frei fürs liegestuhl wrestling wer
jetzt übrigens denkt typisch deutsch
nein das hotel wird vor allem von briten
gebucht und die können das mit den ligen
genauso gut wie wir
[Musik]